This is a site we have built with grids
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now. I copy the
grid's URL from the site and paste it
here.
Hitting okay. I am then asked to confirm
the messenger signature request or the
message signature request.
I hit okay and you'll see I am now
logged in.
Almost instantaneously I am logged in to
the secure client portal and dashboard.
No password, no credential transmitted.
Now I'm going to show you a transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the grid's URL. I paste it
into the grids URL box and I now get a
transaction signature request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay. That's already done.
The transaction settled in under 3
seconds. You can see the transaction
hash. This is the proofof work open
resource blockchain Groot that is the
base of the gauaru making the internet
of economics possible. 1,846,200
times more transactionally efficient
than Bitcoin with 8.23 times greater
network security in commercial use. Both
the login and the transaction were
conducted using grids. There was no
direct credential interaction on the
connected layer, only the origination of
the instruction to the dead drop
protocol.